este vídeo ha sido posible gracias a
surfear y luego os doy más detalles pero
antes vamos con nuestra historia de hoy
[Música]
la india es la democracia más grande del
mundo con más de 1300 millones de
habitantes además es cada vez más un
aliado importante de estados unidos
quizás por eso durante el foro de la
organización de cooperación de shanghai
el primer ministro indio narendra modi
le ha reprochado a putin la intervención
en ucrania el primer ministro indio modi
le dice a la rusia de putin que no es
tiempo de guerras
sin embargo al mismo tiempo en el día a
día la india no se ha sumado las
sanciones contra rusia y además fijaos
en game porta 50 veces más petróleo ruso
desde abril habéis oído bien tan pronto
como empezó la invasión rusa de ucrania
india empezó a comprar petróleo ruso
como si no hubiera mañana y no hablamos
de una subida pequeña casi 50 veces más
zumo de dinosaurio de lo que importaban
antes por supuesto que india no es el
único país que está haciendo caso omiso
de las sanciones económicas de occidente
pensar que el petróleo es la base de la
economía rusa si todos los países
dejáramos de comprar petróleo rusia
apenas podrían continuar la guerra de
ucrania es decir que el hecho de que
india compre tanto petróleo rusia de la
noche a la mañana podría ser todo un
balón de oxígeno para moscú o tal vez no
luego a lo largo de este vídeo lo vamos
a ver pero sabéis que es lo más curioso
de todo esto pues que pese a estas
relaciones tan amistosas entre india y
rusia washington sigue estrechando sus
lazos con nueva delhi no me creéis pues
atentos
eeuu busca incrementar la venta de armas
a la india en mitad de las sanciones
rusas
o se os ha estallado la cabeza verdad
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea desde que
empezó la guerra de ucrania joe biden se
ha reunido dos veces con su homólogo
indio narendra modi en ambos casos las
conversaciones han sido las mismas hay
narendra narendra modi estado y comprar
pétrola rusia está muy pero que muy feo
a ti te parece bonito no ves lo que está
haciendo' putin en ucrania
en arena narendra modi que vamos a hacer
contigo que sepas que me parece muy mal
anda toma 500 millones de dólares para
que te compres armas pero que sepas que
no te lo mereces literalmente eeuu está
preparando todo un paquete de ayuda
militar de 500 millones de dólares para
la india eeuu busca alejar a la india de
las armas rusas con un paquete de ayuda
armamentística un posible acuerdo de 500
millones de dólares pondría a la india
cerca de israel y egipto india es el
mayor comprador de material militar ruso
y todo esto pese a que india está
haciendo caso omiso de las sanciones
contra rusia que es algo fundamental en
la política exterior americana y la
pregunta es por qué por qué la india
apoya a rusia de forma tácita en esta
guerra de verdad india puede salvar la
economía rusa de las sanciones de
accidente y lo que es más importante
porque pese a todo esto eeuu sigue
colaborando con la india y cosas tan
importantes como la defensa hoy vamos a
responder a estas preguntas pero antes
antes vamos a hablar de internet como ya
sabéis internet está lleno de hackers de
cookies y de bots que francamente no
queremos tener nuestros dispositivos eso
por no hablar de que cada vez hay más
restricciones queréis poder ver páginas
web de cualquier país sin ningún queréis
navegar por internet con seguridad pues
no lo penséis más usar una vpn como
surfear vpn creedme el tema de la
ciberseguridad se lo toma muy pero que
muy en serio por ejemplo surf shark
tiene una herramienta que se llama clean
web que bloquea todos esos pop packs de
propaganda por donde se cuelan un montón
de bots y de cookies que son un
auténtico peligro por si todo esto fuera
poco con una única cuenta de surf vpn
podrás registrar todos los dispositivos
que quieras quieres navegar con
seguridad desde tu smart view o desde tu
teléfono móvil desde tu ordenador desde
el portátil desde la tablet pues puedes
hacer todo esto con una única cuenta de
surf shark vpn y por supuesto tenemos
una oferta muy pero que muy especial
para todos vosotros que seguís visual
política básicamente si utilizáis el
código político terminado en cada podéis
disfrutar de 183 por ciento de descuento
más tres meses extra totalmente
gratuitos tenéis el enlace en la
descripción no esperéis más que ya se
sabe que muchas veces dejamos pasar
estas cosas y cuando nos queremos dar
cuenta ya es demasiado tarde y entrar ya
en la página web para descargar la
aplicación podéis hacerlo ahora o podéis
hacerlo cuando termine este vídeo y
ahora sí vamos a ver un poco de historia
entre dos mundos
[Música]
desde el año 1955 india ha pertenecido
al llamado tercer mundo literalmente la
expresión tercer mundo en principio no
era peyorativa y de hecho se empezó a
utilizar en la conferencia de bandung en
1955 en esta conferencia se unieron
todos los países que no querían tomar
partido en la guerra fría si el bloque
capitalista era el primer mundo el
bloque comunista era el segundo mundo
pues ellos eran lógicamente el tercer
mundo en esta lista estaban países como
indonesia yugoslavia y la india pensadlo
bien tras su independencia la india
tenía un sistema híbrido entre dos
grandes bloques desde el punto de vista
político india es una democracia liberal
como cualquier otro país occidental
ahora bien desde el punto de vista
económico india está muy lejos del
capitalismo liberal en muchos casos han
llegado incluso a tener planes
quinquenales al más puro estilo stalin
es decir es un país llamado entenderse
con los dos bloques
[Música]
además a diferencia de occidente la
unión soviética siempre estuvo del lado
de india en temas clave para este país
por ejemplo en todas las votaciones de
la onu siempre han apoyado a india en su
conflicto con pakistán en cachemira a
este respecto a eeuu tiene una postura
mucho más ambivalente y que me decís del
programa nuclear indio en
1974 india hizo el primer ensayo de su
bomba nuclear eeuu respondió con
sanciones económicas rusia sin embargo
empezó a suministrar agua pesada que
asesoría nuclear a la india
[Música]
pero esperad un momento porque la cosa
no se queda solamente en diplomacia y
buenas palabras también hablamos de
armamento y creedme esto es el pilar
básico de la amistad entre india y rusia
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea hasta el año
2016 el 69 por ciento de las
importaciones de armamento de la india
venían de la madre rusia por supuesto
como buen país no alineado nueva delhi
también ha comprado armas a otros países
incluidos los eeuu sin embargo el
principal proveedor con muchísima
diferencia es rusia y os preguntaréis
ahora por qué pues la principal razón os
va a sorprender pero es porque son armas
mucho más baratas simple y llanamente el
armamento ruso que ya sabemos que puede
tener muchos defectos en lo que a precio
se refiere es súper competitivo y como
os podéis imaginar no sólo hablamos de
armas sino también de las piezas para
repararlas el 80 por ciento de las
piezas de recambio del arsenal indio
viene de rusia y la lista continúa con
otros sectores
[Música]
podemos también hablar del sector
energético sí es cierto la india apenas
utiliza gas en su mix energético sólo el
6 por ciento de la electricidad de este
país viene del gas sin embargo en 2019
el gobierno indio y la empresa estatal
rusa rosátom alcanzaron un acuerdo de
intenciones para construir al menos seis
nuevos reactores nucleares de momento la
empresa rusa está construyendo el quinto
y el sexto reactor de la central de
kudankulam una de las principales
centrales del país
[Música]
en otras palabras que las relaciones
entre india y rusia siempre han sido muy
pero que muy estrechas de hecho a día de
hoy seis de cada diez indios apoyan que
su gobierno mantenga lazos con moscú
pese a la guerra de ucrania ahora bien
hablamos de un apoyo ideológico o de un
apoyo convencido o de simple y duro
interés económico pues ahora mismo lo
vamos a ver
[Música]
un paso al este 2 al oeste
en el año 2014 narendra modi se
convirtió en el primer ministro de la
india y muchos diréis pero quiénes
narendra modi cuál es su ideología pues
podríamos decir que modi es un líder
populista muy nacionalista y
absurdamente popular entre sus
ciudadanos para que os hagáis una idea
su partido el bj penn ocupa más del 60%
de los escaños de la cámara baja vamos
que capital político no le falta y
diréis que ideología profes este hombre
pues por resumir podríamos decir que el
programa de modi se fundamenta en tres
pilares por un lado tenemos el
ultranacionalismo al lado de la tendrá
modi donald trump parecería un progre
abraza árboles el segundo pilar de su
gobierno es la tecnocracia modi llegó al
poder con la promesa de acabar con la
hiper burocratización de la india que es
todo un problema y diréis lo ha
conseguido pues esto es bastante
discutible sin embargo el tercer pilar
del gobierno de modding no es otro que
estrechar lazos con occidente y creedme
en este sentido la diplomacia de
narendra modi ha tenido bastantes luces
[Música]
pensar más tranquis está que el propio
donald trump modi fue amigo personal de
barack obama es más obama llegó a
escribirle un perfil para la revista
'time' donde parecía que le declaraba
amor eterno por supuesto como os podéis
imaginar durante la administración trump
nueva delhi y washington se entendieron
sin mayor problema sí que es verdad que
tuvieron algún que otro roce en algún
momento pero en general las relaciones
fueron bien y diréis pero más allá de
las palabras que significan exactamente
eso de acercarse a occidente pues entre
otras muchas cosas significa hacer todo
tipo de alianzas de seguridad porque es
muy simple para defenderse de uno de los
mayores adversarios de la india y diréis
de qué país estamos hablando de pakistán
pues no de otro mucho más poderoso y
mucho más temible exacto china eso
explica por ejemplo que india forme
parte del cual una alianza estratégica
que incluye a estados unidos australia
japón y la india de la que ya hemos
hablado con mucho detalle a varias veces
aquí en visual político pero de nuevo no
sólo hablamos de diplomacia también
hablamos de hechos más concretamente de
armamento
[Música]
[Aplausos]
vamos a ser claros las armas rusas son
baratas porque fallan más que una
escopeta de feria si alguien le quedaba
alguna duda no tiene más que pasarse por
ucrania o ver el vídeo que le dedicamos
aquí en visual política al complejo
militar-industrial ruso como os podéis
imaginar con un arsenal tan defectuoso
es difícil disuadir a una china cada vez
más poderosa conclusión india necesita
poder echar mano del armamento
occidental y creedme en este sentido
moody no está perdiendo el tiempo he
echado un vistazo a esta gráfica
[Música]
para que os hagáis una idea antes de
2016 casi el 70 por ciento de las
importaciones de armas venían de rusia
ahora son menos del 30% francia ya está
vendiendo cazas de combate rafale y
mirage
y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando todos
habíamos dicho que las armas de eeuu son
muy caras pues sí es cierto son
carísimas y de hecho la india no tiene
tanto dinero para pagarlas entonces cuál
es la solución
pues la solución consiste por ejemplo en
crear joint ventures con empresas indias
es decir un fabricante americano firmó
un acuerdo con otro indio para producir
juntos un avión con muchos ahorros de
coste y quizás más limitado que las
versiones norteamericanas pero mucho más
efectivo en cualquier caso que los rusos
cuál es el problema con este tipo de
acuerdos pues el problema es que la
india sigue siendo ese país que está
entre el comunismo y el capitalismo es
decir una economía muy centralizada y la
industria armamentística está dominada
por gigantes estatales hiper
burocratizados como por ejemplo empresas
estilo hindustán aeronautics limited y
eso explica que en el año 2020 narendra
modi abriera la puerta a la inversión
extranjera que ahora puede tener hasta
el 74 por ciento de la propiedad de una
empresa de armas y creedme está medida
ya está empezando a dar efectos atentos
lockheed martin y tata advanced systems
firman un acuerdo donde unen fuerzas
para producir el f16 vlog 70 en la india
sin embargo cambiar todo tu arsenal es
algo que no se puede hacer de la noche a
la mañana
[Música]
rusia sigue siendo crucial para la india
tanto en defensa como en energía y por
eso modi ha decidido no sancionar a
rusia y diréis es una buena idea es una
mala idea pues desde luego aquí en
visual polític no podemos aplaudirle
pero una cosa es cierta la india está
sacando mucho provecho a esta situación
atentos limpia intenta diversificar sus
fuentes de energía con petróleo ruso
barato para que os hagáis una idea antes
de la guerra rusia solo suponía un 0,5
por ciento del petróleo que compraba la
india ahora es más del 10% en abril de
2021 india compró unos 22 mil 500
barriles de petróleo al día rusos en
abril del 2022 la cifra estaba por
encima de los 680 mil y ya me estoy
imaginando el típico listo de turno
diciendo nada ves así es como rusia
puede crecer pese a las sanciones jaque
mate occidente verdad en lugar de vender
petróleo los europeos ahora se lo vendía
a los indios que en principio son muchas
más verdad pues no en realidad quien
realmente ha hecho el business de aquí
es nueva delhi atentos a la jugada
eeuu y europa están dejando de comprar
zumo de dinosaur ya rusia el precio se
ha inflado hasta niveles nacho vidal ya
nos en algunos momentos el barril de
brent ha llegado a superar los 120
dólares sin embargo ningún país rico
quiere comprar petróleo a rusia y ahí es
cuando llega la india y dice hombre
vladimir mi amigo mi cámara mi tocar y
hits tranquilo que aquí está la india
para comprarte petróleo y lo que haga
falta que bien que nos llevamos ahora
eso sí que ya que somos prácticamente
los únicos compradores
aquí nos lo vas a dejar a precio de
amigo
digo yo que nos podrías hacer un
descuento
guiño guiño de unos 30 dólares por
barril así me gusta vladimir eres más
bajo que las pesetas ya rusia no le ha
quedado más remedio que pasar por el aro
dicho de otra forma india ha estado
comprando petróleo muy por debajo del
precio de mercado es decir que en este
negocio hay poco de ideología y amistad
y mucho de aprovechar la situación no
sólo eso europa importaba más de 3,1
millones de barriles rusos al día esto
era antes de la guerra india está
comprando alrededor de 660 mil barriles
al día es decir que en el caso de europa
dejará de comprar petróleo rusia cosa
bastante probable india no va a poder
compensar ni la mitad de las pérdidas ni
por precio ni por cantidad pero ahora la
pregunta es y porqué baiden sigue
estrechando la cooperación con la india
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
el collar de perlas
más allá de rusia la mayor amenaza
contra la seguridad de occidente es
china y en este sentido los intereses de
la india no podían estar más alineados
con occidente es más india tiene mucho
que perder pensad que china y la india
tienen disputas fronterizas de todo tipo
cada pocos años hay alguna escaramuza en
la frontera del himalaya pero sin duda
alguna la peor amenaza es atentos a este
mapa
lo que estáis viendo aquí es la
estrategia del collar de perlas es decir
una serie de puertos financiados por
chinas y colocados estratégicamente para
llegado el caso poder rodear a la india
hablamos de puertos en pakistán si lanka
y bangladesh en principio estos puertos
están pensados para uso civil pero están
pagados por china y tanto pakistán como
sir lanka o bangladesh son economías muy
débiles así que en un momento dado china
podría presionar les para operar desde
ellos su armada
durante años china ha estado ejerciendo
lo que aquí en visual político llamamos
la diplomacia sugar daddy lo hemos
explicado varias veces en anteriores
vídeos que podéis buscar pero en resumen
china puede convertir estos puertos en
puertos de uso militar de forma muy
sencilla y esto es toda una amenaza para
la seguridad de la india eso explica
todas las alianzas diplomáticas y
militares de nueva delhi con washington
y dries pero que puede aportar la india
para disuadir a china ya hemos visto que
su ejército no tiene el mejor armamento
del mundo pues mucho principalmente una
cosa la geografía atentos a este otro
mapa
[Música]
[Aplausos]
esto que veis aquí es el estrecho de
malaca uno de los epicentros del
comercio mundial más del 70% del gas y
el petróleo que llega china pasa por
aquí bastaría con cortar el tránsito de
barcos un día para que los chinos
colapsaran de un momento a otro y diréis
qué países podrían cortar este tráfico
exacto uno de ellos es la india y diréis
pero como podrían hacerlo pues muy
simple veis estas otras islas de aquí
estas son las islas de andamán y nicobar
un archipiélago prácticamente
deshabitado hasta hace poco sólo eran
conocidos por las tribus indígenas súper
agresivas que lo habitaban ahora sin
embargo las cosas están cambiando y
mucho por aquí atentos la nueva base
naval en las islas andamán impulsa la
posición militar de la india en el
océano índico y todo esto explica que
eeuu esté tan interesado en mejorar los
lazos con la india a este respecto lo
que hagan con rusia está en un segundo
plano el interés de washington es que
nueva delhi tenga un buen ejército bien
armado y listo para disuadir a china
todo lo demás es secundario además hasta
qué punto es tan crucial que la india
compre petróleo rusia
[Música]
pensadlo bien en el momento en el que
hacemos este vídeo el debate con la
india está en el tope al precio del
petróleo muchos países del g7 es decir
las mayores economías del mundo quieren
fijar un precio máximo al petróleo que
se compra rusia para que esto llegara a
funcionar todas las principales
economías deberían ponerse de acuerdo
pero parece que la india no está
dispuesta a unirse a esta medida al
menos en el momento en el que hacemos
este vídeo la pregunta es hasta qué
punto esto marcaría una gran diferencia
pensado bien si la india compra petróleo
a rusia es porque ya se lo están
vendiendo muy por debajo del precio de
mercado es decir que con o sin tope de
gasto india sólo está interesada en el
zumo de dinosaurio siberiano y se lo
venden barato conclusión por el momento
no parece que washington esté muy
preocupado por que la india haga negocio
de la guerra de ucrania lo realmente
importante en este caso es la postura
con china y llegados a este punto turno
para ti las preguntas son creéis que la
india llegará a renovar todo su arsenal
militar con armas occidentales sería
buena idea presionar a la india para que
se uniera a las sanciones contra rusia
podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que aquí en visual políticos todas las
semanas así que suscribir a este canal y
darle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un saludo y
hasta france
[Música]